astrophysicist have been telling people
for decades at least since the 80s that
Earth orbits the Sun in a shooting
gallery and asteroids hit Earth they put
life and civilization at risk it was the
1980s where we finally concluded what
was the primary reason that the
dinosaurs were taken out of the out of
the Tree of Life that an asteroid the
size of Mount Everest slammed into what
is today Mexico in fact the Yucatan
Peninsula there's a hundred mile
diameter crater there that is left over
from this impact and we learned over the
decades to follow that you didn't have
to just be there to die you could be on
the other side of the earth and still
die from that explosion because that
explosion alters the ecosystem fires
that are triggered everywhere puts soot
into the atmosphere blocking sunlight
knocking out the base of the
photosynthetic food chain and you can
send a wave of extinction across the
Tree of Life we began to learn this in
the 1980s we've been telling this to
officials to to elected officials to to
government agencies but it took an
actual meteor over Russia exploding with
25 times the power of the atom bomb in
Hiroshima to convince people that maybe
we should start doing something about it
I'm almost embarrassed for my species
that you can be so blind to everything
experts have been telling you and you
got to wait for people to almost die to
say oh oh I guess they are out there
let's put out let's find legislation to
help find them and defend deflect them
so I'm a little embarrassed for us it
reminds me of this comic forgive me I
forgot who wrote it through to dinosaurs
talking to one another and one says
now is the time to build an asteroid
deflection system and the other ones
kind of leaning back not paying much
attention of course they're gone
dinosaurs didn't have a space program
we've got a space program we can do
something about it if people have the
foresight to understand what the risks
are in the dangers and actually act upon
it
so yeah fortunately no one died in the
Ural Mountains of Russia but it's still
an expensive experiment it was a shot
across our bow